best thing the best thing about Marco
Rubio is that he has the potential Niq
among Republican field to be the most
transformative Republican since Newt
Gingrich was very transformative even
since Ronald Reagan he has I think the
best opportunity to bring the Republican
Party into the modern era so you're
saying he's gonna get past the dry lips
thing I think you know Marc Carter III
think he has a natural town I mean it's
more speaker but but it's not just that
it's just he's incredibly intelligent
and he's ruthless
and he's ambitious two qualities which
really really really count for something
yeah his biography obviously is is is
pretty stellar and his ability to
compensate for mistakes impresses me a
lot yeah but but if there's if there's
anyone in this field who has the
opportunity to bring the Republican
Party and on certain spaces in the
immigration and others to a place where
more Americans are comfortable with
Republican policies for example
appealing to the middle class on
economic issues marco rubio is pretty
much the only candidate i think who has
that potential to be and bring the
republican party on the right side of
history is that too much pressure for
one of these guys to be under because
i've heard this a lot everyone's saying
he's the next reagan there's more of a
visionary feel there that that's what
he's gonna bring except that's a lot of
pressure republicans love ronald reagan
i know that much that's a lot of
pressure to put a guy at it it's an
enormous amount of pressure it's almost
an unfair amount of pressure but it's
the job you know that he's signed up to
do yeah and if anybody is capable of
doing it it's it's marco rubio he has
been their best
Venge talent for a long time and and now
is now is his chance so not that the
water thing when he had the dry lips is
that important of course when he had the
the rebuttal to the State of the Union
but do you think it's good that he got a
gaffe like that out early on because I
do think the media does of course we
focus on all these ridiculous things
that happen so he did something that
just was you know it was great for
making gifts and we all watch it a
thousand times but he got like some
silly stumble out of the way and that
does season.you right
usually the earlier the better for those
things and again he was able to make fun
of it very quickly he did some very
creative things with social media that
you know made him pay people understand
that yeah he doesn't
take his himself too seriously takes his
job seriously himself not so much which
which people like it you know lends the
again anything you never say that
whenever you say something lends the
aura of authenticity you're basically
saying it's not authentic but but it you
know it shows him to be kind of a
regular guy he can he can he can fake
being a regular guy pretty pretty well
which is more than can be said for most
candidates and and most of us but but
yeah he again that the potential is
there though I mean the pressure is
there but the potential is really there
he's the real thing